the multiverse has taken us on a wild
journey there has been lots of firsts
and lots of lasts from actors popping up
as early as 2001 or even getting their
start in a car commercial to the
teary-eyed goodbyes we're covering those
moments from all of the mcu spider-man
movies
number one spider-man was a third first
for the fans but a first first for tom
holland tom holland has had more than a
few first days shooting as spider-man
you've got his first appearance in civil
war at first it was pretty terrifying
but he navigated that situation with the
help of a couple of seasoned pros i was
always in such good hands and working
with robert very closely and chris now
his first day shooting homecoming was a
bit less stressful with fewer a-listers
to play off of more noobs he was now the
guy who knew what he was doing it's so
lovely to be on a movie of this scale
but with people that care about it so
much so it feels like we're making the
biggest indie movie ever number two the
first day for andrew and toby was a
weird one for the baby of the little
spider family the day the spider-man
came together was one that caused great
stress for tom holland who had the date
marked on his calendar it was so
daunting for him he brought zendaya and
jacob along to the set for support
once tom met toby and andrew he realized
he had nothing to worry about but the
first thing the trio had to do together
was a wee bit goofy tom said he thought
it was a little strange and almost a
little unfair how they had them put the
suits on and just jump around in front
of the camera together like that was one
of the most bizarre experiences of my
life but he also described it as a
roller coaster that he didn't want to
get off of and it was just a lot of fun
to be able to play with three guys in
spider-man suits the one thing andrew
garfield learned about returning to
spider-man was that he has definitely
aged a wee bit he struggled just a bit
getting back into the kind of shape
where the spandex isn't gonna show
everything up i loved the challenge of
it it was harder as a non-mid-20s person
number three andrew and maguire's entire
part only took two weeks to film and yet
their appearances completely shook the
universe
two universes the mcu and our universe
tom holland has come a long way as
spider-man we can still remember the
hesitancy from audiences before his
introduction a high school kid what a
ridiculous concept
now we find ourselves bawling over his
departure it's hard to believe he's
already been in six movies
here's hoping another contract comes
along soon tom described his last day on
set as bittersweet saying it's the first
time since he was cast as spider-man
that he doesn't have a contract
following no way home unwilling to let
the film end tom kept repeating his last
stunt now i was like please don't take
me out the wires i don't i want to keep
doing this keep doing this
they all cried they were all erected
yeah for like several days it was super
emotional for everyone involved this was
cinematic history the creative team had
planned it out so that the cast's final
day was together a cruel kind of
thoughtfulness
number four hi i'm a big star and i'm
just playing some girl named michelle
being part of homecoming was a bit weird
for zendaya because of course nobody
knew she was mj
touring without spoiling that must have
had her head spinning but more stressful
than that was her first day on set and
her chemistry test with tom holland she
was so afraid she wouldn't get the role
because she was taller and it was a win
for women everywhere when she did
imagine spider-man without her we don't
want to
number 5. spider-man is back baby now
he's got a guy in the chair it was more
like a finally moment for me jacob
battalon was just thrilled that
spider-man was coming into the mcu at
all even before he was cast in the part
i've been waiting for a world where
spider-man can get into the avenger
thing just in general it's safe to say
jacob like everyone else had been
waiting very patiently for a very long
while
number six think you know may think
again marissa tomei just loved her first
day working with tom holland saying that
first day was about that rush of energy
together he just made me laugh so much
it was very easy to fall into the rhythm
with him tomei designed aunt may to have
some of the little things that the other
aunt mays had like an apron and her hair
in a bun and she loved to cook so that's
how her character was introduced but
these elements were quickly removed in
the first scene this allowed the
audience to adjust to the new ant-may in
subtle ways
number seven it took a bit but tomei got
that developed plot she'd really pushed
for for may marisa tomei hasn't come
right out and spoken about her last day
in the movie only my therapist knows the
ending honestly that's fair carrying the
weight of all those secrets would be a
big responsibility had to be
under oath and i had to tell someone but
for her the experience was just
wonderful she stated it's wonderful to
be with this particular cast who
everyone is so talented and so invested
in their characters
number eight the mcu spider-man movies
are fueled by improv and gary less so
improv is not something gary has ever
really done before but her midtown high
news segments were chalked full of it a
lot of her improv came from needing to
play off of her co-anchor who was more
comfortable with improving than her
number nine looks like it's time to say
betty bye sorry if that pun made you
cringe for her last day angari only had
like a 10 second cameo but we loved
every bit of it she didn't realize her
line go get him tiger was an easter egg
that's been in the comics since the 60s
and is also the last thing kirsten
dunst's mj said to peter at the end of
spider-man 2. while she didn't get much
screen time for this film she did get to
do a bunch of the promo material through
betty's internship the daily bugle
number 10 tony is just a fanboy he'd
said it's insane every little kid dreams
of being in a superhero film it's a
surreal feeling and then you see tom
holland who's you know playing
spider-man walk on set in the costume
and you're just like
number 11. star never really got in on
the superhero action so his part was
just all right to film martin starr
actually had his start as roger
harrington in the incredible hulk way
back in 2009 in the spider-man movies
however he enjoyed his little part given
roger doesn't engage with spider-man
really just peter parker playing roger
wouldn't have felt too different from
bill haverchuck on freaks and geeks for
martin it was great interesting weird
perhaps coming full circle now playing a
teacher number 12. from driving teacher
to teacher teacher smoove had a weird
entrance into the movies playing a drive
test instructor in a collaborative ad
for audi with tom holland playing peter
parker smoove joined the cast for the
second movie far from home i'm a caring
person on this on this trip with these
young teens and uh it's amazing man to
be a part of the marvel universe man he
was at first hopeful to be a super but
once i got into the mr dale shell i felt
right at home number 13 superheroes
don't need to be fearless toby they just
need to face their fears head-on
toby mcguire was unafraid of playing
spider-man in the 2002 sam raimi film
i'm not afraid
wow our respect and admiration for toby
maguire just grew it felt very
comfortable i mean i wanted to do it
right but i felt confident that i could
and the lack of fear may also come from
a place of having plenty of time to warm
up to the shoot because they had
rehearsal days he had a workout regime
that started five months before filming
and he had a ton of chats with the
director about the character
number 14. at first fox was thrilled
when he saw the spidey costume years
later he was thrilled to see his own
jaime fox's first day on the set for
amazing spider-man 2 was riling
he said you really get a sense of it
when you walk on the set and you see
andrew garfield in the spider-man suit
wow
this is really
something in history no one will be able
to take these moments away from him
before he ever put the suit on he wanted
the characters to have a weight to them
meaning his character feels spider-man
is his friend almost to the point of
obsession
number 15 the villain who's come a long
way
fox's first day on set for no way home
was exciting because the changes to his
costume really lifted his spirits this
is such a shift from the amazing
spider-man 2 where it was the spider-man
costume that got him excited
it's been amazing man like to be able to
reboot the character new look new vibe
we're loving the new look too kind of
got a flyness to him fox felt that the
team's enthusiasm to collaborate and
accommodate on things like costumes
really made the whole movie better
number 16 we applaud defoe for doing his
own stunts and he keeps up with holland
who's like a third his age tom said i
remember on the last day of shooting
that fight scene when john said cut
willem and i just collapsed to the floor
because we were exhausted and we just
had to give him everything he remembers
chugging red bulls to try and keep his
energy going we wonder if defoe was
chugging red bulls too
number 17. would doc ock have a weight
lifter body if his tentacles are always
doing the weight lifting alfred molina
lost some weight for the role of doctor
octopus wheat he'd gained for a
character named diego and frida he
wanted doc ock to have the build of a
1950s weightlifter molina is a big fan
of marvel comics and was excited about
his role he thought the crew on raimi's
spider-man 2 were the hardest working
group of people he's ever worked with
all of these beginnings and endings have
our heads spinning if we don't think too
much about the complications of time
travel and universe hopping it all makes
perfect sense we're doing something that
people people really love this is part
of our fabric it's part of our culture
jk simmons expects to be in more
spider-man movies though and has us
hopeful for a fourth installment do you
think we will see our friendly
neighborhood kid from queens again let
us know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things